bueno
[Música]
a escala en parís
braulio moro
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con france24 en español
américa latina es una de las regiones
del mundo más afectadas por la epidemia
del coronavirus en enero pasado se ha
superado ya el récord del millón de
muertos y el retraso en la aplicación de
los programas de vacunación podría
llevar a que los próximos meses esta
cifra crezca considerablemente
debilitada económicamente la crisis del
coronavirus muestra que tan frágil es
esa economía pero también da pistas para
ver cuáles podrían ser las salidas a
esta crisis que agita a la región para
hablar de ello está con nosotros pierre
salama profesor de universidad es uno de
los mejores especialistas de la región
quien acaba de publicar su reciente
libro contagio viral montaje económico
riesgos políticos para américa latina
pieza lama bienvenido a esta escala en
parís gracias
pierre salama dice usted fue usted el
primero en escribir un libro
precisamente sobre los efectos de la
pandemia para américa latina y afirma
una cosa que llama mi atención dice la
cob is no precipita la crisis en américa
latina'
ya no golpea a un cuerpo sano
exactamente naturalmente lo que quiero
decir es que se hace 40 años más o menos
pago brazo entonces el tasa de
crecimiento de este dos países de
américa latina estaba entre un punto de
dos puntos en medio cada año en medio
hay que llegar a eso significa que no
hay volvería social poca movilidad
social cuando se tiene solamente dos
puntos se necesita 35 años para duplicar
el ingreso el nivel de ingreso entonces
si se hace una comparación con china por
ejemplo que cumple una situación
completamente diferente seguro punto en
muchos países como méjico de capa antes
de llegar a la pandemia
hubo una recesión en argentina también
en recesión uno de las más fuertes desde
hace 20 años también en brasil hubo una
dificultad de salir de la recesión que
apareció más o menos durante el mandato
de dilma rousseff entonces lo que quiero
decir estamos
de una situación bastante difícil porque
la pandemia llegó dentro de una economía
bastante débil en américa latina una
economía fragilizada a final de cuentas
hay una cosa que usted afirma y que es
realmente sorprendente en todo caso para
mí dice que contrariamente a lo que
piensan muchos economistas en el largo
plazo a largo plazo estamos hablando de
20-30 años américa latina los países
latinoamericanos no son países
emergentes exactamente a excepción tal
vez durante la primera década de los
años 2000 y no pero todos los países lo
que quiero decir que es otro tipo de
mito si un tipo de mito no más la verdad
es que la diferencia entre los niveles
de ingreso entre los estados unidos por
el campo y el precio exactamente en el
mismo que durante los años 60
eso significa que no son economía
emergente el mito no más o sea que
estamos hablando de 60 años donde el
producto interno bruto de brasil no ha
logrado realmente acercarse exactamente
eeuu 3 a cuál es la situación por
ejemplo en otros países de asia a éste
a diferencia por el cap como el país se
rige por el pobre pedir como china o
país antes corea etcétera extra son casi
todos los países emergentes a saber que
efectivamente poner por caso deje nada
ahora estamos cerca del nivel de pib de
de los estados unidos
se le cuenta que se hace 40 años 35 años
40 años no sé exactamente toda la gente
pensaba que efectivamente en la china
era un país muy subdesarrollado muy
diverso pero ahora tiene la capacidad de
enviar de concebir como si nada
ciertamente entonces eso significa que
hay una gran diferencia en salamá la
crisis que golpea américa latina y el
conjunto del mundo claro está llega en
una región donde de una manera general
podríamos decir enfrenta por un lado lo
que usted dice un bajo crecimiento
económico hay un problema de enorme
desigualdad social igualdad social
estamos hablando de ingresos hay un
problema también de un mercado informal
muy grande está también el problema de
estructuras sanitarias muy debilitadas
muy segmentadas entre el sector privado
y el sector público sumado todo esto
podríamos decir que hay verdaderamente
un tsunami social pero que tiene
consecuencias políticas siempre apunto a
las personas exactamente la misma en
todos los países de américa latina a
nivel sanatorio por ello ciertamente la
cantina obras yo tienen gastan más
frente al fin que un país como méxico o
alcampo no es por la salud en entonces
esa situación no es exactamente la mesa
para todos los países de américa latina
pero si hay una cosa que igual en todos
los países de américa latina son es el
nivel de desigualdad de los ingresos es
muy muy muy importante es la región más
desigual del mundo decir sí sí sino con
los cargos los países de áfrica de
acuerdo sí pero son muy muy importante
los que lo que quiero decir eso
significa que la pobreza es muy
importante y subió bastante durante la
pandemia me era bastante estaba bastante
importante en casi todos los países de
américa latina y con la gente sabe una
cosa bastante simple a saber que los
pobres
los que son más vulnerables frente a la
pandemia
y después dentro de que usted a los que
pagan más son los más pobres se acaba de
salir un relatorio de la cepal
se hace más sobresale selección de que
muy muy interesante para mostrar
efectivamente que los pobres pagan el
precio demasiado impreso y demasiado
elevado frente a la economía quiero
decir que eso es estructural saber que
no es una mala suerte es la consecuencia
lógica del derecho que efectivamente
estamos frente a donde llegó el muy muy
importante y una desigualdad que no
parece que se vaya a recortar por lo
menos en un futuro inmediato hay una
cifra que piensa la balanza en su libro
en el libro contagio viral contagio
económico y crisis política en américa
latina que ha llamado evidencia en la
atención y que tiene que ver con la
investigación y el desarrollo una
cuestión clave hoy en día para descubrir
las vacunas para pensar en temas de la
vacuna ya usted cifras que son
verdaderamente sorprendentes korea
el sur que era un país atrasado en los
años 60 hoy exactamente era hoy en día
invierte 4 9% del producto interno bruto
para investigación y desarrollo alemania
y eeuu 2,9 por ciento de su producto
interno bruto en el caso de américa
latina argentina 0 6% méxico 0 6% el que
sale mejor parado es decir 1% o sea esto
es una situación realmente patética
cuando de lo que se trata es
precisamente enfrentar estos nuevos
desafíos exactamente es un país
completamente el nivel de dependencia
frente a las nuevas tecnologías no tiene
la capacidad de producir al suelo
aspecto de riqueza dora y mañana después
de la economía será peor
todo por una razón bastante simple por
una razón de estancia porque voy a usar
las nuevas tecnologías pero no tiene la
capacidad de producirlas entonces eso va
a significar un aumento en el informe de
la informalidad del trabajo una
bipolarización de los ingleses mucho más
importante que en los países
desarrollados
qué hacer para evitar esto pienso que
hacer
completamente la política hay muchas
cosas que tal vez de una cierta manera
puede ser una suerte de suerte para
superar todos los problemas estructural
que conocen los países de américa latina
es un poder más político depende del
movimiento de masas de genera muchos
problemas de este tipo porque se precisa
porque se necesita disculpe de proponer
una política fiscal que su además iguala
más progresiva y reciba en américa
latina' saber que cuando usted pobre no
haga más que información en el censo más
que un médico de impuestos entonces es
un problema bastante importante hacer
una política fiscal de redistribución de
los ingresos puesto implican la
orientación general
en la francia chin chín y una manera de
emitir el índice de desigualdad antes de
los impuestos de la transferencia
y después si necesitas una escala de 1 a
hay una diferencia de 15 15 puntos de
acuerdo en américa latina hay una
diferencia solamente de 2 puntos a saber
que las que las transferencias océanos
son no ayudan no tiene un nivel
suficiente para para eliminar defectos
regresiva de los impuestos ahora bien
quiero usted en su libro plantea una
cuestión que también es interesante por
la coyuntura que se está viviendo por un
lado tenemos el problema de una pandemia
que afecta al conjunto de los países de
la región entramos de nueva cuenta en
una coyuntura electoral y lo que usted
plantea como hipótesis de trabajo es que
esta pandemia podría llevar precisamente
a buscar salidas políticas autoritarias
nos puede explicar un poco esta posición
no tenía posibilidad verdad la verdad
pienso que antes de la pandemia hubo una
ola progresista se inició de unas dos
mil se recuerda por ejemplo de lo que se
pasó en chile para nuestros países
también de américa latina hubo una
un inicio de una ola progresista después
de la ola de derecha bien la pandemia
llegó
todo se paró
ahora podemos ver que tal vez existe de
nuevo este tipo de ahora es imposible
pero lo que me parece de una trama más
probable es que efectivamente aparece
una una ola de extrema derecha en
diferente una hora de exxon derecha en
muchos países de américa latina como
precisamente por el hecho que hay un
peso cada día más fuerte de las sectas
religiosas los evangélicos el que tiene
una grande capacidad de atracción en los
pobres los más pobres y los más pobres
tiene una conciencia de precisamente a
los discursos de los evangélicos ello
semántica se está diciendo que se
necesita de un estado fuerte que la
democracia no es buena etcétera extra
que sobre todo la pandemia es se puede
superar la pandemia si se va a dios
de una manera y para mí era una sorpresa
era también el discurso de amlo
el presidente de méxico el operador
oficialista de la virgen en un país que
después de cada vez era laico
exactamente efectivamente se puede ver
por ejemplo en turquía país laico
también la influencia más cada día
reciente canadá más llamas que siente de
la religión en el fundamentalista que se
puede llegar también en
méxico esto es lo que explicaría en
cierta medida precisamente que usted
hable de los riesgos políticos en
américa latina y sobre todo para la
coyuntura para lo que será la salida de
esta crisis algunos datos méxico por el
prd méxico tiene al 2020 una caída del
pib del plante de más que 10 por ciento
más que 10 posición exactamente 10.1 no
sé regresar a los años 70 eso significa
eso significa que va a aumentar
previamente la desigualdad social para
aumentar la de seguridad y cuando todo
eso se pasa ya que se pasa en una
relación directa con el jefe con el
presidente la conciencia en consecuencia
me parece probable pues estamos llegando
ya al final de esta escala en parís no
me queda sino agradecerles a pierre
salama profesor de universidad es autor
del libro contagio viral montaje
económicos riesgos políticos en américa
latina de front a publicación en español
y en portugués
les damos las gracias en esta escala en
parís hasta la semana próxima
[Música]
[Aplausos]